ted bernard what's up brother
alan how are you thank you so much for
coming on the program absolutely it's my
pleasure
super grateful to evan bliss for making
the introduction uh no that guy he's a
connector
he is yes we've had some great
conversations with him on the program
and he's brought on a lot of our
powerful guests on the show as well yeah
i actually listened to you guys as
podcast i've been a fan of evan i mean
since we've met so
yeah i appreciate him making this
connection hell yeah and i'm pumped to
talk to you about executing ideas
for sure and i love the way that you see
it on a
there's all these creative
opportunities of people actualizing
ideas into the world and that
we need the the proper
allocation of both
the investors the influencers
the execution strategies
for the gifts to flourish and i like
that macro level view that you have
as you funnel the pieces in for
different people to actualize those
ideas
absolutely absolutely i'm pumped to
unpack that
let's launch things off with some of our
favorite questions i'm curious
what do you think is the nature of
reality
yeah i saw that when i when i looked at
your site and i was like looking through
some of the questions your favorite
questions i was like i i was in deep
thought
considering the nature of reality yeah
um so i think
reality is the nature of reality is
i guess um our like social construct
right
so like kind of like the habits that we
have
the um you know the makeup of our
surroundings um and i guess for everyone
that's like
dramatically different because whether
you're in like a rural area
or a city um your reality shifts
right what's important to you shifts the
people around you shifts i think
that with everything we're going on with
everything that's going on in the world
now
i think a lot of people have seen
reality
really kind of become reality when you
think about like
you know working from home and
everything that you thought was like
really important in your life
um it's had to shift you know you have
to like distill things down to the
essence of
um you know where you are at the present
moment and a lot of for a lot of people
that was just stuck at home or for a lot
of people that was like being on the
front lines and
um for them uh the nature of reality
i think was is was very fluid um
so i guess like it's just it's yeah i
guess it's different
um based on where you are who you are
and and your contribution
on on the in the world yeah yeah that's
a
that's a perspective on it that's really
rooted in
the subjective
experience of each individual
conscious agent and so
i'm curious that's a
a very
it's a fairly
a representation that is more
in a sense it can be viewed as something
that is
very much or folk focused
around maybe the the individual and
their
individual experience whether they're in
a rural
setting or urban setting whether they
are of a specific socioeconomic status
what not and then there's also the
sort of and that can be maybe like a
self-actualization
like exterior artistry
north stars people have different gifts
someone just wants to be a good parent
someone wants to be
a business owner of one brick and mortar
store someone wants to be a fortune 500
ceo so there's these all these different
colors on this color wheel
of expression but then there's also like
the self-realization
or the inner engineering or like what is
the nature
of consciousness what do you think about
that
um yeah i think that that uh
i guess that also is something that
is very relative to each person right
because um
you know from a spiritual sense uh and
if
you focus your life around the your your
your spiritual life
then your perspective on that might be
you know your connection to your god
you know um and that's like
consciousness for you uh and then for
other people
it's you know very tangible right
because they are what they do
so them going to work or you know
someone like
who really like focuses just on their
family um
you know that and i don't think anyone
really does this singularly i think
there's some people out there that are
like kind of like anomalies that are
like able to say like hey i only care
about
this aspect and in terms of
consciousness that's what they're like
really connected to um but i think a lot
of us have uh
uh pieces of this that we have to like
put together you know
and and that it forms our consciousness
how do you feel about the
unity of all being in existence
do you feel a oneness
yeah you know like when we when you
mentioned it earlier i
like i i had to like think about it on a
variety of like in
a variety of capacities right and i
think that like
you know 2020 has been this is a great
conversation for 2020 because like
you know we've had to go through you
know
we've had to go through a pandemic we've
had to go through a political election
we've had to go through like
racism right or like to like really
understand that it's actually happening
for a lot of people a lot of people
already knew what
was happening but when you think about
those three things
um which for me that's top top of the
mind um
you know you would really think that
there's like a complete disconnect right
that there is no oneness
um but like i'm a spiritual person so
i tend to believe that everything's
connected and everything happens for a
reason
so my default setting is that there's a
oneness you know i'm an optimist by
nature so
i constantly think that like everything
is working
um in tandem you know so so yeah i do
believe that there's a oneness but like
if you
if you look around and you look online
and you know you you talk to a lot of
people
um that might not be reflected
yeah one of the best ways that i've
heard this explained is
diversity in oneness that's the sri
aurobindo and the mother mir alfasa
and it resonates because it synthesizes
our last couple of minutes of
conversation where you have both
that inner
engineering that true
[Music]
embodied awareness of the unity of all
being in existence
and yet simultaneously the experience
of all of the different conscious agents
the diversity
of life experiences and gifts that are
being actualized
execution of ideas and projects
and that when we hold both of those at
the same time
simultaneity being key that
kind of plants us firmly from our
understanding
on the show it plants us
firmly in what we hypothesize as the
nature of reality which is that you hold
both that oneness
while you hold the unique individuality
that you have and that you get to
express
in the oneness right right yeah i mean
life is duality right
so um there's always going to be like
yin yang there's always going to be hot
cold there's always going to be
you know the the two sides
yeah one of my favorite ways to
visualize it is that we have the
the the duality is how the creation
is being expressed and what
sort of can we can potentially see
transcends
the duality is the unity that
incorporates the duality in it
as in there's one infinite creator
expressing itself through all of the
different realities
including this one and the way that it
is expressed
is through that polarity that we're
talking about between
two harmonic opposites that are in
constant flux
right yeah yeah it sounds like you're
pretty familiar with
that style of teaching
yeah i mean i i follow like uh a lot of
the you know um
kind of same i mean first of all i think
if you listen to or read
anything personal development you're
gonna always like
you know encounter this right because
that's like it's like human nature about
you know when you're like trying to
build yourself up um
when you're trying to grow to like have
to deal with the dualities
um so yeah i'm i'm pretty like well not
well-versed but i
i pay attention oh yeah yeah i like how
you also bring it to the
to the level of as
a really interesting synthesis in
what we talk about in chapter two of
high level perception in this idea of
trajectory mechanics is that you have
what can be viewed as a synthesis
between physicalism
with something like newton's third law
of motion
that the every action has an equal and
opposite reaction and a very spiritual
perspective which is that
the ascent and descent happen at the
same time
so meaning something like
as you're in your personal development
the individual is undergoing something
like
the beauty of like the actualization of
their gifts or their execution of their
idea
what would typically happen is something
like wow i've made a massive step in the
upward roller coaster direction
and it's like yes and then it's like the
next day
like you're usually sent on some sort of
a descent
and it's because you're now more
prepared you're more equipped and this
is why people like
carl jung from studying tens of
thousands of
of psychoanalysis of different people
was able to abstract out a pattern of
that
the roots have to reach hell for the
fruits to reach
heaven and that's why the
entrepreneurial journey
is usually one of the most
roller coaster-esque processes
yeah i i can see that and i mean there's
a lot of
yeah of course there's a lot of truth to
that i don't actually i don't i don't
look at it so
um when in terms of entrepreneurship i
don't think that i don't look at it so
um so in depth i think it's like kind of
actually just really simple
um like pursue something you're
passionate about and like
work hard and i think that like life
whether you work hard or not and
whether you pursue something that you're
passionate about or not like life is
inevitably gonna like
throw you some blows so like if life
will
inevitably throw you those blows you
might as well be as equipped as possible
to handle them so that's why you like
pursue what you're passionate about and
work as hard as you can
so i mean i've like looked into like
i've read sam walton's book about you
know building walmart
and and it's very interesting because
like
you know in retrospect people are like
man he's like the richest like he was
the richest man in the world and i think
when he passed away he left
like 10 of his family members on the top
like uh
top richest people like top billionaires
like top 20 billionaires were like half
the walton family right
um or half of the list was the walton
family and like when you read his book
i mean of course like he wrote it so
like you know
you got to take out a great assault but
um i think that while he was doing it he
was just
going at it you know he didn't think
that he was going to be the richest man
in the world doing it he just
kept on going and i think that this is
like kind of like the distilled version
that i like to look at like
entrepreneurship as
yes i like that highest level
abstraction of identifying what the
north star is and just pursuing that
with
vigor on a daily basis i love that very
simple
refined distillation of it and then if
you double click in
and look at it at the higher resolution
you can
equip yourself with words like nasim
tuleb says anti-fragility
right so you want to take basically the
stressor that you experience
the trauma and you want to quickly see
it as a treasure and as a gift
and as wisdom that you can bring to the
world and things like this
sort of the more that you see those
higher resolution pieces to the journey
as well
the more equipped you are and that's why
mentorship something crucial because if
the mentor tells for example i didn't
have
somebody that was telling me when i was
19 moving to silicon valley that hey kid
anti-fragility is super important use
your traumas as your greatest treasures
now we get to provide that to 19 year
olds that are currently in their process
and we can act as
as that piece for them my question to
you would be that
as you identify that highest level
abstraction of identifying
what is your north star and then
pursuing that
with a deep amount of vigor every single
day
what would be not only your
journey of how you identified what that
is for yourself but also what you're
seeing
as a pattern for how other people are
identifying it is it something like just
exposure
to the different options on the buffet
and then sort of intuitively figuring
out
what is that north star
yeah i mean well i started in
entrepreneurship
um like i was 16 years old when i first
started my
like started my first company so like i
pretty much always knew that i wanted to
be
in business so for me
um i guess like i didn't really
try to identify anything it just like
kind of came to me um
and then over time i guess maybe
probably my dad
also being a semi-entrepreneur
you know had a lot of the books
uh around i remember him like um kind of
forcing me to read the one minute
manager
at the beach i hated reading so i was
like just
skimming through pretending i was
reading
but i ended up actually like finished i
actually ended up reading the book and
then like he always had like les brown
around
and when i was younger i was like a lot
more hardcore hard focused on like
just doing so that's why i like kind of
pushed out some companies really fast i
raised like
you know my first round of funding when
i was 19 for a startup
um and now i mean i barely finished
college right i mean i i didn't even
want to do that that was a waste of my
time at that point and now
i mean in the past like several years
i've been
doing i did more reading in a in like a
year than i did like in four years of
like high school
you know so like i really double down on
that
um so for me i think that i've always
i've always known like kind of what i
wanted to do like i think life just
pushed me in that direction i never
actually went
out searching for it and um
now i just kind of like have a more to
like tuned in focus focus if you will
because like when life happens
you start to understand like what's
really important um
and and what's like kind of fleeting so
you know when i was younger and i kind
of just was only focusing on like the
making money aspect of things and
i started to get to know more people
that had a lot of money
but got to see like how their lives were
you know
and i was like oh snap i hope i don't
get
all this money just to like not end up
having like
some of these more important things you
know so uh
so i pay attention to that a lot more
than just like a north star that
basically
you know dictates what i should be doing
based on like my passion or purpose
you know i try to make sure that i have
all the tires with air
in them this is super interesting
both that you identify your father's
entrepreneurship as something that was
part of the
catalysis of your interest in
figuring out your own entrepreneurial
passion
but also that you give this analogy of
all four tires
of the human vehicle having
a solid amount of pressure in them
in order for the vehicle to be really
strongly roaring
along and the question would be
something like what are your
four tires i would say like
lifestyle relationships career
and um community
okay let's do this don't ask me to
repeat it
i heard lifestyle community
relationships
and career okay so
lifestyle relationships yeah
okay
community and career yeah for sure
okay
and
lifestyle relationships community and
career
so let's unpack the nuances
of this in these different tires on the
car
right what does as we
execute ideas into the world as we
pursue these north stars
what are the nuances of each one of
these tires that
ensure that we are living a maximum
well-being
process along the way like what's
lifestyle let's start with that
yeah i mean um it is it's different for
a lot of people
right so like i guess like people have
to just like understand what
is important for them for me lifestyle
has always been able to have a sense of
independence
um so i always wanted to be able to like
kind of just do what i want when i want
um and so
being able to travel being able to meet
the type of people i want to meet
um being able to like represent
like like illustrate my personality with
the way that i dress or
the way that i you know act or the way
that i speak that's always been
important to me
so so that's lifestyle right i mean to
me just like
being able to uh you know be yourself
and kind of do do things the way that
you want to do it
reminds me of that alan watts quote
the artist that does not pander to the
gallery
yeah it's pretty interesting so and if
you
and if i think that you become that
artist that like
uh that you know the the audience is
like
too much in favor and then you might be
doing something wrong
that's super interesting too that's a
cool way to put it like
if the audience is if you don't have
haters you're probably doing
something a little bit wrong yeah i'm
trying to get some myself you know where
i can go get something
i'm not i'm not a big like you know i
i'm i'm yeah i
i don't really i guess pay attention
enough either um so i don't actually
ever see them but yeah it's
i i think that's exactly what i was
saying you just need to be able to make
sure that you're always like
kind of developing you know and in order
to grow you need to have a little bit of
like that pain factor you need to be
able to
go against the grain a little bit
totally yeah to be to be actually
growing
dude people are insulting me in the
comments section on this channel
all the time it's so funny like yeah
word like
like on at least like usually at least
on
on every episode there's usually a bunch
of positive comments about like the
guest and like what they're teaching and
like
myself as an interviewer and then
there'll usually be a comment
on those episodes that are something
about negative about
about me but especially on the ones
where
it's just me when i do like like
yesterday i did the
a stream on my heroic dose of
psilocybin that i took on saturday which
is
five grams of an entheagen that then
awakens you to the nature of
being in reality and there were a lot of
huge flood of positive comments and
there were a decent amount of
negative ones and that's been a
reoccurring theme as i
do these breakdowns of my metaphysics
and my ideas about what the nature of
consciousness and being is and stuff
like that
and it kind of makes you wonder like
like you know the way that gary
vaynerchuk and a lot of other people
kind of
reference this is like you kind of
you kind of feel like you kind of feel a
little bit bad for people that
spend their time on writing negative
comments to other people
like well i think them for the
contribution then you think that you
thank them for the fuel as well
yeah hey thank you like what kind of a
state of consciousness do you have to be
in in order to write a negative comment
like i haven't written a negative
comment to somebody in
years and it's really nice yeah
yeah no i was just gonna say i mean i
don't i don't like uh kind of pay
attention to it
in either way because i think that
people in their journey
are in different places so i guess i
never know what people are going through
um when they actually sit down to write
something or to say something or to do
something
and i think that like hurt people hurt
people so like they essentially
yeah so if someone's saying something
negative or doing something negative you
kind of have to also like have a little
sympathy
and think like you know i hope they like
develop
you know in a way that kind of gets they
get past something like that
yeah but yeah you know exactly yeah
that's a
we've heard that on the show so much
hurt people hurt people
yeah yeah and that the evolution of
consciousness is moving people
away from that malevolence and more
towards that enlightenment and it's it's
really nice
so lifestyle was heavily focused on
independence i like that a lot
how about relationships yeah um
relationship is tiered i guess like when
you think about like
um family friends
your i guess romantic partner um
i think a lot of that is shifting um on
how we look at
relationships because of kind of
i think all the technology around us and
like being able to like get around you
know like i have groups of friends in
different parts of the world because
um technology allows that you know there
was a point in time when we were like
you left high school and like you never
saw those people again
yeah and now they're like all on my
facebook yeah so like
you know that that shifts a little bit
like relationships but
and and in general though like life is
about
like kind of who you have around you and
being able to have lo
you know those though that ecosystem of
people um so that's something that if
you you know if you're not
you got all the money and everything
else but no um
relationships in you've done you've got
a terrible go at it
yeah interesting i like the i like the
breakdown
again the tiered breakdown of it and
family romantic friends
it's kind of like you said it's an
ecosystem i like that a lot
and then let's do community
um community i focus on like um
when i when i say community i i kind of
hyper focus on like
um like kind of your like your spiritual
community
and being able to like give back um so i
think that it's really important to have
like
a group a good um circle of people that
kind of keep you grounded
and i think in that circle is people
that you volunteer with
you kind of give back to like people who
are less fortunate
i think that's like really important
a focus there on spirituality giving
back
in community it's strong like that
now for career
yeah and you know it's funny because you
i didn't like put them in any specific
order but i think you hit the nail on
the head
because i would uh put career last
because i think you know we spend a lot
of time
focusing on what we're doing and you
know we identify with that a lot and
i think when you're like you know if
you're pursuing something you're
passionate about
is great i mean for a lot of people it
takes it
it takes over so that's why it's really
important to have the balance
um but yeah i think career is really
important because if you if you like
we're put
we're here we're put on this earth my
belief is that we're put on this earth
to like
work to to create um and i feel like if
you're not
if you're not doing that then then
you're missing a huge part of it and and
you're likely unfulfilled
despite what you may you know trick
yourself into thinking
yeah i like that a lot as well so we
have
the breakdown of career like in that
passion and that north star that we are
we are literally here
to create and that we need to identify
what that is and simultaneously we need
to identify
what the true nature of our being is at
the same time that's that
interior self-realization of that one
infinite creator and that
exterior artistry of our unique north
star actualization
i like this a lot so i might need a copy
yeah
this is why this is why we do it on the
pro on the program yeah
we do these visualizations this is
and it happens over and over again with
our different guests is that you know we
get these breakdowns of
what their sort of ethos and and
pillars are to their
their being and then we share them with
other people
and we play the tennis which kind of
helps unpack it
and so it's usually really insightful
like this one
and so then maybe my my next question
about this
would be something like
now do you
look for these
as patterns
is this would you say a pattern of
of maximizing your your well-being
as you pursue a north star
i don't follow the pattern part that
when you focus on these
tires in the car
that the pattern is to
identify that you want to ensure that
you have strong relationships
like that you want to ensure that you
have a deep amount of spirituality and
that you're giving back and that once
these tire
the pattern is that you make sure that
the pressure is being filled
in these tires i wish um but i think
it's just something i know
um and like as you go through life i
mean unfortunately on a day-to-day basis
i don't
uh look at this and say hey are you
hitting all these checklists
um unfortunately i'm not there yet uh
but
i think you know at a high level i know
that these things are important
so like half the battle is just like
kind of acknowledging it and then making
sure that i think that
as you acknowledge it throughout like
your life it kind of gets fulfilled one
way or the other
yeah i like that it seems to be very
intuitive for you and i like that a lot
and sometimes it doesn't need that
quantified self data visualization
component of it but sometimes it can be
really helpful because then you can
actually visualize potentially what the
pressure actually is in the tire whereas
sometimes
it can be difficult to make that
realization until
maybe something is occurring where one
of your family members or your friends
is feeling like
you know in that relationship tire that
they're not
they're not feeling you yeah i'm like
failing a half of it
[Laughter]
especially like well-being is such an
important one it's like this constant
reminder to take care especially of the
physical vehicle
yeah then ensures that everything else
downstream is successful
would it be
fair to sort of unpack your
macro level view on
the process of
the formation of almost famous group and
as we sort of unpack that part of your
your journey is it is it fair to say
that you also look at these things
in the entrepreneurs and the influencers
and the investors that you add to your
ecosystem yeah for sure i think that
like um
when you're pursuing uh
i don't want to say only business but
when you're pursuing opportunities
opportunities for friendships
opportunities for business opportunity
for anything right i think that you have
to kind of
look at how those like types of people
that you want to you know
connect with uh how they fit in to your
you know kind of life plan um i had a
friend
who told me something really interesting
it was like the first time i heard it
she was basically like
when you pursue an opportunity it either
has to be like
financially rewarding you either i mean
if not all three but financially
rewarding
um or be with people that you really
want to work with
or an idea that you really are
passionate about
so it should fit into one of those three
because a lot of times we take work just
because of the money right because we
need it and we're just like hey i don't
care what it is i'll just do it
but other times we take on opportunities
especially in the startup realm where
it's just like really cool people and
you just know that you connect and a lot
of incubators
um they focus on the people because if
the people work well together it doesn't
matter what they're doing
um they're gonna be successful at
something um and in other people just
like
like an idea right maybe they evangelize
around a certain thing that happens
all the time in like politics right like
people are like really
uh certain about the democratic party
republican party and they pushing that
direction despite who's on who's the
head
um so uh yeah i think that in general i
pretty much try to
try to focus on like making sure that
people fit you know my framework
and then what would that sort of
be like where someone does
fit into that framework
and then how do you sort of add them
into this
funnel of your ecosystem and then
allocate these like puzzle pieces and
resources into the proper kind of trains
of ideas that are being executed
yeah so i think that like um in life you
kind of meet like or in business you
meet like a variety of types of people
right there's some people that just have
you know a lot of money but can't come
up with an idea of like how to use it or
they probably have a lot of ideas on how
to use it but
maybe nothing really interesting to them
you know um
you know some people they just have more
money than they know what to do with so
uh in that scenario you want to make
sure you're like getting people who
or in that scenario you want to make
sure that like you kind of find
something that they could be passionate
about
that the money is an afterthought you
know they're like hey you know i just
want to pursue this idea
um like if you try to go in with like if
you try to go in with
like hey i'm going to make you a lot of
money from the startup you know that's
like a really cool like obviously people
want to make a lot of money if they
think they're going to be a unicorn that
helps a lot
but you might not want to lead with that
if you're not like
you know there's like a lot of people
that can like promise a lot of money if
you go to any banker they'll like give
you a lot of options you know
um real estate is like something
everyone goes into so what you really
want to do is really
be selling them on like what type of
lifestyle they can have
because of this type of business you
know or what type of relationships they
could build because of this type of
business
and the money be kind of like oh you'll
make money too but that that may not be
the core focus
you know um i probably shouldn't be
saying that a lot of people are like
i want my buddy but i think that's like
a huge part of it right um
like that's why everyone goes a lot of
people go into entertainment because
like i mean is it lucrative yeah but
is that like the core thing that people
are going in it uh going into it for
not really right they're going into it
because they're passionate about that
like
they like the idea of being on a world
stage and being able to like walk on a
red carpet that's important to them
express themselves yeah yeah that's a
big one
so so that i i try to focus on like
bringing those types of people together
there's like in
throughout history they've always been
like the artists
and their um and their like patrons you
know like the people who like actually
support them
um and and so i feel like when you're
like building a startup
uh that's kind of like you always got to
bring those two people together
yeah looking back even 500 years ago we
had the medici family that
catalyzed a mass amount of the
the artistic renaissance and also the
scientific
because of patroning michelangelo and
raphael
and botticelli and da vinci and galileo
and similarly today when we look at
the way that venture capital structures
work
that there is a sort of
investment into the equity
of the idea that catalyzes it
yet there seems to be still some sort of
like
missing component because
not all ideas are ones that are
generating
money and
this has been really difficult for many
especially
scientists engineers that are trying to
you know help eradicate some sort of
like
neurodegeneration but then it's like
it's gonna take me a year to three years
just to get to a little bit of proof
that what i'm doing is eradicating some
of those
beta amyloid plaque tangles that occur
in the formation of
alzheimer's disease and
investors typically want to identify
something that is like
software scalable you have an amount of
customers and
yeah yeah that's it's a definitely a
hard balance right there's definitely
like
low attention on a lot of um on a lot of
uh
you know industries because it's not
cool enough so
uh but i think it balances out you know
i can't really say that but it balances
out to some degree right because like
you have like you know wealthy people um
suffer the same challenges as like
everyone else right so like
you know when you find like you know
build bill gates
mom died of cancer right so like i don't
know this but i'm pretty sure a lot of
his
a lot of his money is going towards like
cancer research you know so
i think that there's like this happens
throughout time uh
quite often where someone like suffers
an ill fate and they're just like how do
i make sure this never happens again
so like they use against all logic they
basically like
plunge into you know different types of
industries because of whatever for
whatever reason you know
some people go into homelessness because
they're just like you know i had like
you know
whether i went through it or a family
went through it though you know they
think like
i never want to see this happen to
someone again you know and so without
you know
if the is there a way more balanced way
of doing that um like just distributing
funds
um i'm sure right uh but you know people
i'm
i feel like life in general kind of like
balances out
over the course of time yeah yeah over
the course of time for sure and then
there's also
sort of making it so that we
do the light architecting that we're
actually
talking about because we can't live in
the world
of our
vision of having less suffering and more
basic needs be met
and more gifts being actualized if we
don't take those fundamental steps that
are required like in 1906 when we had
the american antiquities act with john
muir and teddy roosevelt we looked at
our national parks and we were like
we need to make these sacred
where you can't just come in and just
absolutely destroy them for capitalistic
purposes
and so we did that process and now we're
sort of starting to figure out well
maybe
we should treat the psyche
our mind also as sacred
space as well divine space as well maybe
i shouldn't have to
have the perverse incentives of the
business plans
of the attention economy that are
mining my data and my attention
and creating asymmetries in that
and feeding propaganda into my
psyche based on that there's double
edgedness to the sword of course
because you can also get a
recommendation of something that's
really strong in a good
alignment with you but
these are sort of the ideas that if we
want to
make it so that a beyond the venture
capitalist and the founders
of a company that you have
like what silicon valley introduced into
the the ecosystem a couple of decades
ago was that
well let's start having the employees
earn
equity as well on these vested cliffs
that happen every single year
and so that's a good way to sort of
stakehold more people into the equation
maybe the founder and investors
each take just a couple
less percentage points and they
distribute that across the employees and
maybe one of the next things you want to
do is you want to say well
okay well maybe beyond the employees
maybe the customers
themselves the ones that are actually
creating
a massive part of the company's wealth
maybe they also deserve to
earn tokens or shares of equity
in the company as well then goes to the
stock market
and so then an example where that's
countered
in a sense because it's a good point is
that
it doesn't matter if the company goes to
the stock market
if the example driver
for uber let's say has been generating
let's say 25 000
a year in wealth for uber
but they have been earning zero tokens
in the ownership of uber and uber is a
private company that is not public
and even if it was publicly available
and it was being
traded as tokens or shares that driver
further maybe they've been driving for
eight years
maybe they've been driving for uber for
a long time at twenty five thousand
dollars a year of wealth generation
that would be two hundred thousand
dollars of wealth generation for uber
yeah they deserve a stake of that yeah
that's like a little bit of um
i guess as as an entrepreneur like i
guess i think about it
kind of two ways right because like um
uber is like a very risky
business uh like ride sharing in general
when it first came out was like
you know who'd have thought that it was
going to be successful right i mean like
we've always been told not to get in the
street
like into the car with a stranger so
they took like a lot of risk
to launch their business so just because
someone decided to like start using my
product as
either a producer or consumer
i don't think that i owe them anything
right so
now when i do decide to let them be part
of my company
i think that's when like they could buy
like that's when my company goes public
and there's other platforms there's a
lot of websites now where you could be
kind of a micro investor before they go
public
so if that driver like if if uber had
that sort of plan in place like some
like other startups that aren't as well
funded as as uber does
if they had that plan in place then um
then of course you can
there's a system to for you to
participate but case in point is like
most on average that person that's like
driving for uber um if they
let's just put it this way that they're
not on these other platforms investing
in startups that are risky
you know what i'm saying so like they're
not going on like republic or like
startup engine
and like putting themselves at as an
investor and saying hey you know what i
use this product so i want to like
uh you know participate and it's
financial stability
um so so i kind of think different about
that because like you never know uber
can still flop
you know um it's still very risky uh
you know airbnb throughout covet has
gone through like
a lot of challenges now the question is
whether or not someone who like let's
say is an airbnb host
wants to go through those challenges
with airbnb
like would they be willing to lose money
like will they be willing to like
go into debt for it for for airbnb you
know what i'm saying so like
i look at it this way because i don't
think that just because you know
just because the company's you know
doing well and i use their product
or i like participate in their ecosystem
i just automatically are owed you know
in a sense to me on a macro scale
it's as though every human on the planet
deserves
a share of the
pie of our planet
it would be weird for me to not feel
that way
you know like
deserve is a strong word like
just because you woke up well
and this is where your assessment is
very accurate which is that
this sort of heterarchy
a decentralized approach
also incorporates a hierarchy within it
at the same time
because the person
on the color wheel that has a north star
that is
around providing a good or a service or
something of value
to millions of people around the planet
in the hierarchy is going to get
rewarded with a greater share of that
pie
that we're talking about and someone
that's waking up
and is a good parent or
citizen in the world is going to get a
lesser
share of that pie but that they still
deserve a share of that pie
just like the biodiversity of the planet
deserves a share of the pie
for example the phytoplankton that is
currently
across our oceans that is
undergoing the photosynthesis that
provides us with 70 percent
of our oxygen that we take
20 000 inhales per day of
they deserve to be an inclusive
stakeholder in our planet's success
but right now they're not which is why
we
are acidifying the oceans and we're
also polluting the environment that we
don't
realize has an interdependent
relationship with our own existence
so you see how the inclusive
stakeholding idea
in terms of everything having a share in
the
pie of the planet's
trajectory makes sense at the level of
our interdependence
and unity yeah i think that the way
you're describing it i don't know if it
translates directly but i can see how
loosely it translates
i get it in other words
yeah and i'm working on being able to
sort of story tell this
in ways that are more and more
convincing and relatable
and yeah i mean a lot of people share
this thinking i mean there's a new
um concept ubi universal basic income
that and
rather than ubi it should be ubs
universal basic stakeholding this is
what you know as you say that
i've already underwent this process by
running these
economic simulations it's not about
getting income itself it's about
actually having a
stake which then gives you income but
you
are an actual inclusive owner rather
than just getting paid
out and so that's the next step beyond
the actual income
is to be a stakeholder and get paid out
a dividend for your stakeholding
right i get what you're saying yeah i
think that um
i've never been a fan of like like
nepotism like i've never been a fan of
like just getting something just for
just because like you're in line like
you know so i i feel like
yeah like that i guess that's an
interesting concept i've never thought
through it like this because i've never
like you know had to
but um but that's a very interesting
uh uh train of thought
it's really interesting that
there's this balance between what we're
talking about in the sense of
i agree with you so much on how
in that hierarchy within the heterarchy
there must be a disproportionate
asymmetric
reward for those that hustle
and execute a divine vision
that brings value to other people at
greater levels
than those that are potentially
doing something that may be consumption
oriented on a day-to-day basis solely
if somebody is solely
playing the video games that other
people are producing
and focusing maybe 10 hours a day on
that gaming process that
unless there is also a component of like
there's the
emerging esports leagues that
exist and maybe they're contributing
value in that sense
or maybe they themselves are also
interested in designing and producing
the games as well or creating
communities around the games that
they're playing and creating value that
way
there's myriad ways to create value
but if you are solely oriented on a
consumption level you are inevitably
going to get less
of what the pie is and so i definitely
agree
in that sense simultaneously but on a
planetary level
i definitely want to ensure that
the basic
nutrient needs
are being met and that's why
you know we spend so much time
on the program indicating like in high
level perception
in chapter one we talk about this
analogy between the tree
and the human and that the
nutrients at the root level of the tree
need to be met in order for the tree to
produce the fruit
very similarly with the human that those
basic needs need to be met
at the nutrient level in order for the
human to self-actualize and self-realize
both the nature of their being and a
unique creative contribution into the
world and that's why
you have things like the united nations
sustainable development goals that are
obsessed with getting us to zero pop
i i don't currently know and the planet
doesn't currently know
what we're missing out on
creatively as unique contributions
of people around the world just because
they don't have
the basic luxury of
tap water and that they have to carry
a jerry can on their head for kilometers
to a well
and then bring it back every single day
and spend that time on that
and that's something to
to explore you know another thing here
as we were saying before is we don't
know if there's
actually models for these
unsdgs that are
entrepreneurially
create the incentives that then make it
so that investors are super interested
like on a planetary level how many high
net worth
investors are
you know thinking about what
they can do by funneling financing
into the meeting the basic need of
water around the planet without needing
to
get a one-year return on that
investment or two years that's not the
issue the issue isn't uh
uh i think the gap from
kind of the gap between
the person needing water in a third
world country or
even someplace to be able to use the
restroom and
like the financing and availability for
as a society
as a as a world to be able to provide
that that gap in between that like the
is corruption right there's like a lot
of corruption there's like a lot of
abuse
um there's a lot of like i mean
yeah just in general there's a lot of
stuff in between that that
and disables that financing to get to
the people
um so so so i don't think it's just like
uh
i don't think it's like a like uh you
know a war on capitalism that like
you know hey we need to break this thing
up or this is bad because these people
are suffering it's like
you know if you go to like i've been to
bangalore india
and like i you know talk to the folks
like that that are actually there
and they're like now we have a lot of
money but it's just like
i probably shouldn't say this but it's
like it's a corruption that actually
stops that
stops them from getting the roads made
because money's there
but it just doesn't trickle down and
promulgate the vision to
to other people you're right that
corruption is something that's
massively impeding meeting the basic
needs and
actualization of gifts around the world
and
furthermore though it it seems as though
the core
of what the most upstream issue is that
then leads to
all of the downstream things that we're
talking about around people
that are choosing to be corrupt
or where people are choosing to not
identify these basic needs that need to
be met around the planet to
actualize these gifts the most upstream
thing
is consciousness
so the most upstream thing is that
the more that somebody realizes
the true nature of their being
the interdependence of everything that
exists
the unity of all being in existence
when they see the self
in the other when they see that the
other is actually another self it's like
an
other self when you get to that level of
consciousness when you're experiencing
things
that are in the transpersonal and the
non-dual
space everything downstream
unfolds frictionlessly perfectly
how does that resonate well i think dave
chappelle makes it like
like a funny joke where he's like like
because he doesn't really believe i
think he was listening to like the
secret or something or reading the
secret
and i kind of like got through like a
couple pages of it and he threw it away
because he was like um someone made a
someone made a
um i mean he he understood like you know
like
oh you so you need to tell me that like
if these kids in africa just like
understood like you know the secret then
like they would no longer be hungry or
something like this and he was like
no that's not the case like so for a lot
of people it's not like self
self actualization or like um
consciousness right i mean
like they're fully conscious they know
what's going on they're just like in a
scenario
that like in a situation that's like not
advantageous for them you know
so like i think that if we decided to
break down borders and like anyone could
be anywhere they wanted in the world
then i feel i feel like we'll find like
the playing field even up really quickly
you know so i think that like a lot of
people are like
they they know what they're capable of
you know they work really hard
but they just don't have like that
opportunity like we're lucky
being born in the us you know having the
best economy in the world you know
um you're even more lucky white male
you have every opportunity you know so
like there's like i think that
life deals we we get these cards um
but there's like a lot of things that we
can do with these cards right like
because
there's like a lot of people
yeah there
appears to be a
layers of complexity around the
unfolding of
consciousness that makes it
more multivariate and nuanced to
identify some of these most
downstream expressions of it
i see a lot of the things that
you describe as
downstream expressions of consciousness
and the social fabric
and the structures that
we've put it into
and that on a most upstream point for me
is the protocols the architectures
the
biomimicry of what
currently exists like in
mycorrhizal networks which is where
there's
a two-way resource exchange that happens
underground between
fungi and 95 of plants that
intelligence right there is a billion
years old
and it's just very hubristic that we
think
that my 25 35
45 year old existence
is going to experience something
downstream and i can solve something
downstream by targeting something
apparently
downstream whereas it appears as though
the most
upstream thing is where
the leveraging
what was deployed approximately 12 years
ago with
the bitcoin white paper and the
acknowledgement of
what can happen with the
decentralization protocols and you can
use tokenomics
you can use smart contracts
you can use what
is an embedded biological archetype it's
like why the internet evolved
you know the internet evolved because
it's a biological archetype
like we can be viewed as cells
in the organism of the planet and that
the cells want to frictionlessly
communicate with each other across the
planet and that's why the internet
emerges without
a sort of
uh there's without molasses there's not
much
molasses the internet is pretty
frictionless
yeah and that's why the decentralization
regarding things like cryptocurrencies
are also
like you were saying earlier when you
sort of loosen some of the border
structures and you make it more porous
you actually enable the frictionless
exchange of value across the planet with
what will be bitcoin and ethereum and
all of these other cryptocurrencies
plus you'll enable more creativity like
you say when the porosity
of borders loosens up as well
and it's very clear that we're heading
towards that more globalized world
but at the same time you have seven
thousand languages on the planet right
now
projected for that to drop to 3 500
languages in just the next couple of
decades so we're going to lose half of
the planets languages and it's being
concentrated
obviously in english mandarin arabic
spanish
yeah and so there's also this driving
force of nationalism
that is we can be not
disgusting about it we can be not
disgusting about globalization as well
if you drain
the dirty bath water yeah
and this is why you know we we make
these graphics because
it succinctly describes what we're
talking about this is
in chapter 7 sorting algorithm you need
to drain the dirty bath water
from nationalism and drain the dirty
bath water from globalism
and you need to rescue the baby from
each
and marry them because you want to
retain the unique
languages around the planet yeah because
that's
that's beautiful it's a cultural
expression yeah it's beautiful
yeah well i think um this there's a
parallel
to like all of that like when we talk
about ecosystems i mean
when it comes to like business um i've
been
always fascinated with like marketplaces
simply because of this like
you know like ecosystem and it obviously
is um
you know obviously has this connection
to nature and and like you know
mankind's history um so i've always been
fascinated in this sort of thing
uh it's it's kind of like really the
driving force of of my business i really
like to bring
different parties together um you know
and i think when you do that
uh over time you start to see like a lot
of
development you know synergies uh and
and
and in that you you solve a lot of a lot
of problems that that
are around
yeah this is
to view the world from a
a market's perspective is extremely
enriching and important and
simultaneously to balance that
in a sense we can view it again like the
sorting algorithm which
again feels very archetypal as we were
discussing earlier on the program that
the one infinite creator expresses
itself as
these two poles that are constantly in a
flux
and so in this case with what we're
talking about
it can be thought of as markets and
economics
is one of the poles right and we have to
in a sense we have to balance the
economics and the markets
with something like indigenous wisdom
and things like nature and things like
science balancing itself with
spirituality modernity balancing itself
with indigeneity
that when we do that and we
filter out the dirty bath water from
both those things and we take the
good fruits from them and we bring them
together
that enables us to more and more
create the that better future that our
hearts know is possible
but that
requires these sort of like visionary
abstractions that make it easier for
people to realize
what we're most optimally meant to do
to meet the basic needs to eradicate
suffering to
create more abundance and more
flourishing and more prosperity
yeah so to me it's very much driven
around
like the most visionary abstractions
about the optimization
of civilization and
in a very like protopia sense like
protopia meaning just
incremental bettering and
yeah there's a very deep relationship
between
myself and everything that exists
and
this would be the 0.1 unique difference
of every single person's unique
contribution and gift
in the symphony it's like your solo that
you're playing in the symphony
and so that's how the creation expresses
itself
it expresses itself with an inward one
infinite creator
and an exterior infinite artistic
expression that's unfolding through
these unique
individual conscious agents and so
to me there's nothing that's more
important than
the most upstream which is that
self-realization and meeting the basic
needs for more
self-actualization to occur and it's
really
deeply intertwined with the executing of
of ideas
i i i agree i agree
um i think uh i think that yeah when you
when you think about these
um kind of just different ecosystems and
like
kind of putting it all together uh i
think that
you find that we naturally uh kind of
create this like this bat the balance
happens
um like i was mentioning earlier where
you like naturally want to like solve
some of these problems
and i think that like when we talk about
executing ideas
it it lends itself to like
folks that are like they have a problem
or they see a problem
and they kind of construct a solution
and they use their ecosystem to be able
to come together
and say hey what's the best route to
actually like you know
come together and and and
execute this solution you know so um
yeah i definitely i that's why i'm a fan
of like kind of like putting together
marketplaces putting together ecosystems
because
just bring together a group of people
and i think when you do that it becomes
really powerful
i want to ask you about this because it
it really resonated with me what you
were just saying
in regards to they're sort of like
as we're talking about like 7 000
different
languages around the planet and it's
undergoing like an ethnographic
condensation down to 3500
in all of these different communities
across the planet there's these
different
philosophies these different ideologies
these different
essences expressions creativities
uniqueness
of being in these little cultures
and so within their ecosystems they have
different ways to solve problems and
some of them just straight up
leap frog a lot of the existing ways of
of solving problems i think it's really
interesting when you look at
things like like africa doing a big
jump in some ways in some countries
around
getting beyond the the the telecom
infrastructures and jumping straight
into mobile and jumping straight into
the things like m-pesa enabling the
banking through the mobile
systems i i wonder if there's
more of that that can be enabled across
the planet
based on the regional
areas creativity and meeting their need
regionally and versus in a sense
thinking about it on a on a planetary
level because in that region there might
be a solution
that's more optimal given their way of
life
and living that is better for them
than on a planetary level as we say
is saying let's install clean water taps
inside of the community and maybe
their response is something like no
we i mean i can only talk about where
i've been um and what i've
what i've seen firsthand i mean um and
you know
moving back to the us and specifically
la
from dubai and while i was there i was
uh
in the philippines and
spent a lot of time in europe and
india and i've been able to see like
just how they do things um and in other
spaces and i think one of the most
interesting things for me was how uber
operated in india you know when i first
got there i thought
you know no way was i going to be able
to get like you know
you know um you know they don't i don't
know if
they get a lot of credit for like you
know being able to
uh build things uh you know locally like
dubai is only like
if don't quote me on it but i think
there's only like three million people
there
so you know and um they're kind of like
really small
but they've been able to do some like
really innovative work and that's
because they
they've been empowered to do it right um
i think and that's what happens when you
give people like opportunity you get
people from like
kind of all over the world it's a
melting pot and and they've been able to
come up with some really good
um uh ideas and and
um you know just talking about executing
ideas they've been able to just get it
done
you know like between the burj khalifa
tallest building in the world done in
like
such a short period of time palm islands
like that's literally like a man-made
island you know
um they like really uh uh when
when blockchain and cryptocurrencies
were coming out they
they they really spearheaded a lot of
that stuff um
so i thought it was like really
interesting when you know you when you
look at
like globalization and and it's you know
the shift that it goes in to like
localization
um i think you you start to get like a
lot of creative ideas
yeah that's so spot on i like the idea
of equipping people
like you say with your passion i think
that's spot on very similar to
the way that i see it and as we equip
people
locally they end up doing what whatever
they want creatively and it's that
sort of fabric of opportunity that then
enables people to pursue what localized
creative processes our problems and it
needs to be done in a balanced way
where there's like a relationship a
co-creative
relationship with that with these
regions of the world that that
enable them to figure out that this is
how we optimize
yeah and it's exactly what you said too
because there's a lot of places where
you know what we find um really
important
uh they don't feel the same you know so
it's like i think that like just because
we um look at something a specific way
doesn't mean that we have to like
um impede that on other people you know
doesn't mean that we have to like
pressure them into like
you know kind of feeling the same way
about something i i think when we think
about
all the people in the world um you know
it's like
how many do you need to be on your side
you know in order for you to be
successful
you know so if you look at it from that
perspective um and i i think this is
like the benefit of like localization is
like you don't need the whole world to
agree
with your the way you run your grocery
store if it solves like your local
problem and you're happy
then by all means continue doing your
thing i love that
spot on is something that we were
talking about
um before we started that i want to
unpack with you
is the
i went through an experience also
around about
eight years ago or so where i i went to
jail for four months
due to trafficking cannabis oh wow
that's a long time
yeah and it was interesting they didn't
tell me that earlier before
it was those pounds it was like seven
pounds and it was in south dakota
and that's you know and so we were both
we're both very passionate about
driving reform to where we unleash
people that are currently incarcerated
in the u.s
especially lake yay says meanwhile the
dea teamed up with the cca
and you can't have private prisons and
you can't have perverse incentives that
drive more people to become incarcerated
and that especially when they're there
for cannabis which is a joke
and that people deserve to be with their
friends their families their creative
expression and as a in a very
intelligent way decriminalize and
legalize for medicinal and recreational
purposes
all cannabinoids hemp in the united
states give me some of your thinking
around this
yeah it's a very similar um that's a
good question because that's it's very
uh uh similar to what i mentioned
earlier about corruption
and these other countries that like
prevent
you know the idea of you know financial
freedom
um and the actualization of that you
know getting down to the people right so
like the war on drugs is specifically
that is like corruption
you know um and and i think when we
think about like a lot of like
you know people of color like just being
disenfranchised in this country
um it stems from corruption um so like
it's not that people um you know
need a handout or something uh
it's more that they the system needs to
be
fixed and then balanced out you know um
so yeah i think that like
i got into like cannabis like actually
um by mistake you know
moving here from dubai like all drugs
are like completely illegal
um and i wasn't much of like much into
like
cannabis uh before that either right out
it was in dubai for like five years
um so i obviously knew it was around but
for sure since i was on the east coast i
wasn't really as educated about it as
as a lot of people on the west coast and
the west coast they've been fighting
this fight for
a very long time so kudos to everyone
that's been really like
um uh applying pressure so that we're
even at the point that we're at now
um so uh when i got into cannabis i
specifically
um got into it because uh again with
like
you know the combination of investors
and um you know
building out you know projects with
teams uh i had
an investor that was interested in
building out a marketplace in the space
um building out technology in the space
but i worked with him
in you know his company in dubai on
building a marketplace
and so he you know tapped me as big
being the per like a good person to like
spearhead like technology and we kind of
bounce around some ideas on what that
would look like
and that's where we came you know again
my my background
specifically being in my being in
marketplaces that's when
you know we came together on like
building a marketplace for the cannabis
space and
only when i started to get into it is
when i started to understand
exactly what's happening i was like very
uneducated um and still
like it's a lot of work to really unpack
things
because like you know the more act just
passed and um
you know there's a lot of like hooray
from a lot of people
that think you know that's like a really
good step and a step forward but
there's also like a lot of um uh
wording in there that kind of keeps a
lot of people like people of color
uh disenfranchised right so i think
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done there and i think like the starting
point
is i mean there's a lot of social equity
programs and things going on and
you know we'll take everything right or
anything
to start but i think um you know the
first thing that should have been done
and should be done is just like like
everyone that's in prison
because of anything cannabis relate it's
like really
it sucks that like there's people right
now operating businesses where
they're like making you know so much
money
and there's other people that are doing
the same exact thing
they're in jail so i think that's like
the first thing that needs to be done
get them out um
and then the second thing that can be
done um is then
like equipping them to like like really
uh uh
um some sort of uh rehabilitation right
where they're able to like get into
business that they were already doing
you know and then from that point on
there's other people that want to get in
because they like me who are like
know not much about cannabis but i just
think that i can add value
from a technology perspective and so
just like enabling folks like me to be
able to say hey you know what this is
like the one industry
that we could have an equal playing
field we could we could we can
be playing on an equal playing field you
know um so i think that's like kind of
the next step in cannabis
um so i think there's steps there's a
lot of people fighting a fight like
there's a lot of activists that are
really knowledgeable
and they have a platform so they're
doing a lot there's a lot of folks doing
a good job in communicating
what needs to happen but i think of
course there's a huge gap between like
the activists and
government officials actually taking
action on kind of the right thing to do
there's a there's a mixed message on you
know what they believe is the
right thing to do so um yeah there's
there's a lot of work to be done in this
space
it's kind of stuff isn't
nuts we've had steve d'angelo on the
show several times and
he's unpacking the and tim blake did
this as well
just the massive lineage of several
decades of blood
sweat and tears that has went on in
especially california here in terms of
the process of
getting back the this beautiful
secretion from our planet that is here
to serve us
and i feel very similarly about
entheogens and psychedelics across the
entire planet
they're here to serve us heal us awaken
us
and that they can't fall to the same
perverse incentives and forces that have
that have centralized and that have
capitalized
solely from a profit driven perspective
and that they need to be prioritized in
a decentralized
healing and awakening perspective across
our planet
and it's nuts that you can have
something like someone that's
incarcerated today for years
and even decades for something that
someone is legally doing
today now so and the rehabilitation
process
and is uh is is critical and and again
eradicating the corruption has a lot to
do with the consciousness you can't have
somebody that
is in a state of deeply egoic
self-dealing consciousness that is
in a place of congress or in a place of
running a fortune 500 company you can't
keep pumping
high fructose corn syrup as coca-cola or
pepsi
into civilization social fabric and then
pushing all the downstream
effects onto the healthcare industry
when the people in those positions are
awakened which they are slowly becoming
more awake and
they're doing things like wanting to uh
have
only clean ingredients in their in their
products
and that's slowly creating the social
fabric as well as the
the individual awakening to what is a
more beautiful
future on a cannabis front on hempfront
entheage and psychedelics
consumption of information consumption
of products
in general and sort of seeing it from
that
that most upstream perspective over and
over again for me
has been kind of what has helped me
realize that especially for people in
positions of power
we need to see like have you ever had a
non-dual experience in your life
have you ever felt the unity of all
being in existence because if you
haven't
and you're in congress then you're
almost surely going to have more
self-dealing
incentives
so i really reason from this perspective
conceptually
and it seems to be most upstream
you're more likely to take a bribe from
the pharmaceutical industry or from any
lobbyist
that has a perverse incentive of wanting
to promulgate their
high fructose corn syrup or whatever it
may be if you haven't ethically or
morally or spiritually awakened yourself
and so viewing it from that perspective
is
it's like you need to become a a channel
for
for christ consciousness buddha
consciousness loud sir confucius level
consciousness the highest
possible level consciousness which then
makes everything downstream much better
i want to ask you another question this
is one of our silly questions that we
like wrapping the show with
what's your favorite food uh
what's my favorite food you know um
man i like everything yeah yeah it
depends on my mood
so i go from like
i go from like i guess like
grilled chicken to fried chicken
sushi to like yesterday i had a
like like i just really wanted thai food
yep so like it just depends i go through
a season of stuff
yeah yeah like i really like sweets but
i like as a rule i'd never buy it so i
wait until there's an occasion like a
birthday or something where i know it's
gonna be there you know there you go
so i just wait yeah yeah so yeah so i
like everything but
it just uh it yeah it depends on like
kind of you know what mood i'm in
especially like in california like
versus like let's say
dupai or miami right because like in
california like you get like a lot of
mexican food
uh there's a lot of ramen i've never
seen so many ramen restaurants
yeah and so but a lot of it is delicious
you know
so yeah i like everything but it depends
on my mood and kind of like
where i am and you know
do you like cooking yourself i'm a huge
fan of cooking yeah i'm a huge fan of
cooking i've been doing a lot of it
especially with this pandemic uh
i've had to learn and it saves you a lot
of money
are you cooking are you cooking your own
grilled and fried chicken not fried
grilled gorilla i try to be healthy
yeah yeah but i like literally just had
like fried chicken the other day i
haven't had it in
so long and i was like because it's not
really like i feel like
you can't really get it a lot of places
like a lot of restaurants you go to
aren't like
and like it's super difficult to cook
like right i mean like you gotta it
takes more time
yeah and you have to get oil and yeah
i'm good on
you have to get the batter to actually
stick on the chicken which is one of the
hard parts too
i've been doing bolognese and i've been
doing like
i've like baked chicken asparagus
uh and like sweet potatoes i love that
i'll do this huge fan of that yeah sweet
potato and asparagus are two of my
favorite sides as well yeah
yeah yeah so so yeah i've been i've been
doing a lot of cooking so
it's it's really cool like i mean
throughout this time like we've had like
a lot of opportunity to like look within
right so like basically
you know i think like between like
cooking and focusing on like
like really like i want to say your
personal development but i feel like
that's like kind of just
like like um uh diluting it you know
but like being like you know with
stay-at-home orders here and there
you know things opening up and then
closing like soon as things opened up i
started to really think about like
what is the most important thing to me
you know i was like what did i miss the
most
so in a lot of cases i was like going to
like some of my favorite restaurants
that just opened you know
one thing that i really wish happened
was like um you know music venues
uh like you know i love live music and
that's like something i've like really
missed throughout this time so
that kind of sucks but um but yeah like
just i think
in this time period i've been able to
like focus on like you know just being
able like
when i when i think about cooking and
putting together ingredients it just
reminds me a lot
um you know it reminds me a lot about
like
you know myself and business you know
like when you think about like
these four tires that we talked about
earlier and like making sure like
i just you know like think about like
what are
what's going to be done after you like
put those ingredients together you know
exactly so yeah
and that's a great way to to wrap is to
reconnect on these points these tires
lifestyle relationships community
career under lifestyle independence
under relationships family romance
friends
under community spirituality giving back
under career
passion north star
beautiful yeah yeah
thanks for coming on the program thank
you for having me i really appreciate it
it's been great
it's been really fun yeah so uh what
happens next how does this work
so now we thank our audience
thanks for tuning in everyone who
greatly appreciate you
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you think about everything
that said sharon with us about
executing ideas we'd love to hear from
you you can check out the links in the
bio below
we have both ted's website we have his
instagram profile we have his linkedin
profile go give him a follow
go and connect with him on those
platforms
reach out if you'd like and support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
spiritual leaders the scientists and
engineers around the world that you
believe in support them and help them
flourish you can support simulation our
links are below to our show help us
execute
our biggest goals out here as well
and that's all folks execute your ideas
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in
thanks ted thanks evan for making the
intro we love you very much too
and go and build that future more
beautiful future our hearts and most
possible
see you soon thanks alan thank you guys
thanks dad
peace